ce soir c'est la saint valentin mais
aussi PSG - Bayern Munich un choix
cornélien pour les fans de foot qui
doivent choisir leur camp et convaincre
leur moitié entre les deux leur cœur
balance et ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un huitième de finale de la Ligue des
Champions tombe à 14 février bonne
soirée sur les réseaux sociaux beaucoup
de supporters semblent avoir fait le
choix de la raison et certains sont durs
en affaires si elles m'attend jusqu'à la
fin du match et Paris gagne on peut
basculer en mode Saint-Valentin une fois
je pars travailler oui je reçois un MMS
de Victor avec une grosse boîte en
carton je me dis il me dit qu'il a une
super surprise qu'il est trop content
que quand je vais rentrer vraiment ça va
être super qu'il a hâte que je rentre
combien est-ce qu'on va dépenser pour la
Saint-Valentin ça c'est intéressant 142
€ en moyenne 28 € de plus que l'an
dernier c'est énorme parce que c'est une
moyenne j'ai été franchement très
surpris en fait avec l'inflation la
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat on aurait
pu s'attendre à ce que les Français
dépensent moins pour la Saint-Valentin
en réalité il y a une explication c'est
que l'enquête elle prend en compte
uniquement les personnes qui vont
célébrer la Saint-Valentin et ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas les moyens cette année ne
célébrons pas et donc n'entre plus dans
les statistiques
je me prépare je suis dans la voiture je
suis là oui oui je prépare à dire oui et
là je rentre la boîte en carton je
l'ouvre
quatre enjoliveurs pour maintenir
mais non le budget moyen des Français
pour cette Saint-Valentin serait en
baisse les Français vont dépenser en
moyenne 83 € ce soir contre l'an dernier
bah oui mais inflation oblige on a
réduit le budget on sait aussi que la
Saint-Valentin est devenue ringarde aux
yeux des jeunes seul 38% des moins de 35
ans avant la fêter bon côté cadeau c'est
du classique le top 3 c'est fleur
chocolat et parfum ceux qui dîneront
ensemble pourront tester la dernière
tendance en matière d'art de la table le
spaghetti dump le jeté de pâtes de plus
en plus d'internautes américains s'y
mettent prétextant que cela évite
d'avoir à laver la vaisselle c'est vrai
mais niveau présentation et hygiène
c'est une autre histoire une assiette
c'est bien aussi autre sondage mené par
Kappa nous apprend que cette
Saint-Valentin sera particulièrement
chaude au travail cette année 51% des
Français croient de nouveau à l'amour au
travail cette année c'est 10 points de
plus que l'an dernier et faire l'amour
sur le lieu de travail est un fantasme
pour 92% des Français
c'est un coup de cœur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et une feuille selon l'analyse des
écoutes des utilisateurs Deezer nous
sommes d'humeur romantiques à l'approche
de la Saint-Valentin le mot-clé le plus
recherché est amour et il y en a une
bonne dose dans les titres les plus
joués à cette période perfect de Ed
Sheeran
l'évidence Someone Like You de Adèle
ou encore l'un des tronables All Of Me
de John Legend
[Musique]
des déclarations d'amour affichées aux
quatre coins de la ville comme chaque
année ici comme ailleurs les panneaux
lumineux appartiennent l'espace d'une
journée aux amoureux chacun avec ses
mots peut déclarer sa flamme à l'élu de
son cœur sur la place publique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons tous en montagne les bons
comme les mauvais moments je m'a apporté
tout ce que je souhaitais dans ma vie
des beaux enfants à domicile et tout sur
le plan professionnel tu as su
stabiliser ma vie personnelle et
professionnelle et pour ça je t'en
remercie du fond du coeur je t'aime la
boucle est bouclée il ne manque plus
qu'une chose
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait le
lendemain du divorce nous avons anticipé
avant de rentrer chez le juge en
réservant le restaurant et le 14 nous
sommes allés fêter la Saint-Valentin
mais avant tout notre divorce et nous
avons été au restaurant tous les deux
ils sont allés fêter leur divorce c'est
pas beau ça en tête en plus tout à fait
vous êtes trop mignon
félicitations
quel est le secret de votre longévité
dire toujours oui à sa femme ouais ça
c'est vrai comment on dit les femmes ont
toujours raison les hommes n'ont jamais
tort quand on veut aimer bien on ne
compte pas la preuve presque une heure
par jour en 55 minutes pour être précis
c'est le temps moyen passé par les
célibataires utilisateurs des applis de
rencontre et cet usage c'est totalement
banalisé mais pour quels résultats et
quelles conséquence soit la santé
mentale par exemple en ce jour de
Saint-Valentin un point s'impose
2,6% de la population française est
inscrite sur la plateforme tinder un
million 740 000 utilisateurs en France
c'est en Bretagne Estelle et en
Occitanie qu'on trouve le plus
d'inscrits si jamais ça peut ça peut
vous aider alors il y a tinder merci
pour moi tout va bien merci 70 % des
utilisateurs de ces applications à vous
avoir un impact négatif sur leur santé
mentale créer un profil qui se démarque
demande énormément de temps et d'énergie
une étude néerlandaise a montré que le
nombre de matchs les affinités
virtuelles étaient directement corrélés
avec l'originalité du texte de
présentation il y a aussi beaucoup de
pression autour des photos et du
physique et puis il faut aussi arriver à
gérer les rejets qui peuvent se cumuler
c'est pas toujours évident physiquement
vous n'êtes pas seul on n'est pas seul
j'ai découvert que le corps humain
compte beaucoup d'habitants notamment le
démotex je sais pas si vous connaissez
c'est un parasite le démodex des mots
des modes
c'est un parasite qui vit dans nos cils
et qui sort la nuit pour avoir des
relations sexuelles avec un autre
parasite sur le visage donc je suis ravi
de savoir que ma peau est une maison
close allez on se quitte en chanson avec
les mots de Johnny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un cri quand c'est moi qui dit non
quand c'est toi qui dit oui que je
t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime